bonsoir à toutes et à tous vous êtes sur
tv fil 78 pour un nouveau débat du 7-8
société la question du soir les produits
cosmétiques que nous utilisons au
quotidien sont ils nocifs pour la santé
vous pouvez participer au débat poser
toutes vos questions à nos invités en
passant par le twitter de l'émission
hashtag 7,8 société le mois dernier
l'ufc que choisir a publié une enquête
qui a fait du bruit pour cause
l'association de consommateurs a passé
au crible des centaines de produits
cosmétiques
le résultat est sans appel puisque des
substances toxiques des allergisants des
irritants des perturbateurs endocriniens
ont été trouvés dans 185 produits testés
185 de quelles molécules toxiques parle
l'enquète quelles en sont les
conséquences sur la santé notamment chez
les nourrissons
pourquoi des industriels sont ils à les
utiliser dans leurs produits si ces
substances sont nocives que font-elles
encore sur le marché et enfin quelle
alternative y at il pour y faire face du
bio du fait maison ou d'autres choses
encore pour répondre à ces questions
trois invités autour de la table on va
commencer avec marie gendre bonsoir vous
êtes chef de projet ile-de-france pour
l'association y mustapha larfaoui qui
est connue déjà des téléspectateurs de
dv fils d'un bon soir
vous êtes pharmacien président de
l'association pharmaciens pharma
citoyens et beaucoup de choses entre
voilà on va pas tout citer
et enfin philippe fleurait bon soir ça
vous êtes président de l'association ufc
que choisir versailles et sa région
on va commencer avec vous justement
philippe férez puisque cette enquête a
fait beaucoup de bruit comme on à dire
l'introduction beaucoup de produits
toxiques trouver dans ce qui a été testé
par l'ufc que choisir est ce que vous
pourriez rappeler d'abord aux
téléspectateurs en quoi consiste cette
cette enquête comment elle était réalisé
concrètement cette enquête a été
réalisée à l'initiative de l'ufc que
choisir auprès de laboratoires ou
d'organismes spécialisés donc qui ont
analysé les produits que nous avions
proposée alors sans appel puisque on a
dit totalement l'introduction il ya 185
produits testés dans lesquels on a
trouvé des produits toxiques alors vous
les avez classe en quatre catégories
c'est ça oui il y à des produits donc
qui ont érigé un caractère l'allergie
produits allergènes des produits
irritants des produits perturbateurs
endocriniens et puis il ya loin des
produits toxiques
quatre familles de produits qu'est ce
qu'on appelle perturbateurs endocriniens
les perturbateurs endocriniens ce sont
des produits qui dégagent des substances
qui peuvent perturber le système humain
l ufc s'attendait à avoir des résultats
telle que celle que cela on savait bien
sûr mais pas passer le pas ce niveau et
donc que c'est pour ça que ça nous a
conduits à réagir et un publier cet
article
justement vous regardez une première
image 20 premières infographie qu'on
retrouve dans le lent kg est ufc que
choisir donc du mois de mars
et vous voyez il ya douze produits les
plus dangereux m il ya beaucoup plus de
production était acquis ont été montrées
et dans tous ces produits on le voit il
ya des perturbateurs endocriniens des
irritants des allées argent d
allergisants etc etc alors mustafa
rahman reposer on va poser la prochaine
raison puisque vous êtes pharmacien vous
connaissez très bien ses produits et ses
produits on les retrouve également en
pharmacie dans beaucoup de produits
notamment des produits que j'utilise
déjà je tiens à dire que je ne
représente pas la pharmacie française
dans mes propos puisque je suis
pharmacien mais je ne suis pas là pour
parler au nom de la pharmacie française
et encore moins au nom de l'industrie
des cosmétiques j'ai donc parlé en tant
que pharmacien dont ses limites dont
c'est notre métier la première chose la
première réaction que jaurès et de
remercier que choisir puisque après tout
est ce que les téléspectateurs peuvent
concevoir que nous pharmaciens qui
vendons s'est produit entre autres cela
pas tous mais entre quelques-uns qui
sont vendus en pharmacie qui sont nés en
parapharmacie ou dans d'autres circuits
de distribution est-ce qu'on peut
sérieusement penser que nous les
pharmaciens qui les distribueront les
testons nous mêmes les valides ont avant
de les vendre
et puis surtout la grande question qu'on
pourrait éventuellement se poser c'est
est-ce que le pharmacien a vocation à
intoxiquer ses clients donc par
définition on a on fait confiance c'est
un réservoir en liga sur le pharmacien
ou l'inde où l'industriel et donc par
définition ces molécules là qu'ils sont
cons été montré à l'instant sont des
molécules que j'ai apprise mois dans
l'antre guillemets dans le cursus cursus
scolaire elles sont connues et reconnues
à l'écran depuis mal on les voit à
l'écran depuis maintenant des années
donc ce sont des molécules qui sont
utilisés depuis très longtemps dans
différents produits cosmétiques et
autres
donc en fait bien évidemment que la
première chose que je pour la première
chose que j'aurais envie de dire c'est
moi quand je quand je voi enquête
je suis tout aussi interloquée que les
consommateurs et donc je rends hommage à
tous ces gens qui travaillent autour
parce qu'on a un bien commun ce sont ces
la santé publique
on a un bien commun c'est de faire en
sorte que ses produits ne soient pas là
pour être toxiques aux gens et aux
consommateurs c'est très très joli ce
que vous le dit mustapha larfaoui mais
c'est pas joli c'est vrai mais les
produits par exemple mais justement
beaucoup et nous pharmacie dans les
cuves lampard mon pharmacien encore une
fois je rappelle d'autres circuits de
distribution existent ils sont parlé
aujourd'hui je crois qu'ils se sont pas
présentés donc moi je viens au moins
pour vous le dire on a un circuit de
distribution également de médicaments
les médicaments c'est par monsieur qui
dira le contraire il existe également
des effets secondaires on n'a jamais
retiré tous les médicaments parce qu'ils
avaient un effet secondaire par contre
on les décrit on n'a pas retiré du
circuit pharmaceutique tous les
médicaments parce qu'ils étaient à effet
notoire toxiques
donc je suis pharmacien et il ya une
chose que je sais que je retiens et que
je dis aux téléspectateurs c'est que que
ce soit des médicaments que ce soit des
produits à partir d'où ils sont actifs
ils ont une action réelle et sérieuse
alors ils peuvent induire une toxicité
ce qui est important c'est de voir à
quel niveau de toxicité parce qu'il ya
des mots il ya des moins importants mais
quand on dit que ces allergènes
moi je veux bien un allergène la fraise
est allergènes est ce qu'on va faire une
enquête sérieuse sont des fraises qui
sans allergènes celles qui développent
des toxicités induites donc 1
je ne vais pas défendre l'indéfendable
simplement on a un circuit de
distribution qui fait que quand on à
l'industriel les pouvoirs publics qui
nous disent c'est toxique il faut le
retirer
alors nous sommes les premiers avec un
circuit de distribution à les
entraînements efficient pour les retirer
rapidement marées marées jambes un petit
mot peut-être une réaction sur quand
vous avez découvert tout simplement
cette enquête ufc que choisir et 185
molécules toxiques dans ses produits ça
vous a surpris ou pas du tout alors nous
à l'association migraine ont même déjà
depuis plusieurs années des ateliers sur
les cosmétiques des ateliers de
sensibilisation qui vise à informer en
fait le grand public sur bas comment
décoder des emballages
comment du coup aussi pouvoir faire des
choix en fait en connaissance de cause
de produits peut-être plus responsable
et s'est donc étonné pas forcément
directement puisque c'est des choses
déjà dont on entend parler un certain
nombre depuis un certain nombre de temps
maintenant forcément c'est voilà du coup
l'idée aussi nous dans nos ateliers
c'est pas de prendre position par
rapport à tel ou tel produit
mais plutôt d'amener les gens à
connaître à s'informer et du coup après
à pouvoir faire leurs propres choix
alors est ce que justement pour sa forme
et on peut regarder ce qui a marqué sur
les étiquettes
regardez la liste des ingrédients mais
si comme vous pouvez le montre est
d'ailleurs un philippe fr vous avez un
petit un petit guide l'acquis et
d'enduits fc que je veux dire dans le
dans le magazine du mois de mars
il ya une carte repères avec les
molécules toxiques ça voudrait dire est
que quand on fait les courses on est
obligé de se balader avec ça et puis de
regarder un petit peu tous les
ingrédients de chaque produit qu'on
achète alors ça multiplie dans des
courses là alors bon
ne nous affolons pas si je puis dire
déjà dans un premier temps c'est vrai
que les mots employés sur sur les fiches
produits sur compliqué un beau beaucoup
de français les pharmaciens petit
retrouve un mais un consommateur lambda
est pas capable de comprendre sid lee
voilà donc c'est pour ça que nous avons
édité donc ce petit dépliant qui peut
être mis dans un zoo un porte monnaie
ces gamins par exemple d'affaires
prospère et s'est classé par ordre
alphabétique et donc ça permet d'attirer
l'attention sur des preuves des produits
ou des ingrédients à surveiller on va
dire parce que comme comme ça vient
d'être dit tous ces produits bénéficient
d'une autorisation administrative sur le
marché seulement ce que l'on sait c'est
que ce qu'on s'aperçoit c'est que la
science fait des progrès continuellement
et que certaines molécules qui jusque là
était considérée comme celle sans danger
peuvent se révéler combiné à d'autres
poser certains problèmes pour certaines
populations c'est pas forcément pour
tout le monde et les nourrissons les
femmes enceintes
d'où la nécessité est ce que disait ma
voisine informé aide à former et d'être
resté vigilant voilà la
pharmacovigilance est une science à part
entière qui a été pour le coup inventé
par l'industrie pharmaceutique la
pharmaco vigilant jusqu'à jusqu'à
maintenant on vient de retirer un
produit
voilà je vais pas faire de la publicité
pour les produits mais encore
actuellement dans la dans l'actualité on
a entendu parler d'un médicament qui
était distribué de façon massive
convient de retirer du marché il y en a
eu plein comme ça la pharmacovigilance
et quoi c'est des pharmaciens sentinelle
toutes les pharmacies y compris la
mienne et y compris tous les pharmaciens
de france nous sommes des sentinelles
des vigies pour relater des incidents
qui nous sont rapportées et l'industriel
est censé lui même faire cette vision
mais dès qu'il ya le moindre soupçon ou
pas on a parlé du parabène par exemple
le parabène est un très bon exemple qui
par définition ils étaient même jusqu'à
dans la substance même des parfois des
matières et des biberons et un réchaud
parabènes nulle part donc l'industrie
pharmaceutique et la pharmacie en
particulier je parle pour eux pour le
coup en mon nom mais pour ceux qui nous
regardent les pharmaciens
on a besoin de vigie différente de la
propre vigilance personnel ensuite pour
dire un mot sur ce que lorsque madame
fait je vous rappelle que les
pharmaciens d'officine faisait ce qu'on
appelle des préparations de registre âme
et qu'on a fait de la cosmétique très
tôt avec des émulsions les émissions
classiques aux dents huile dans eau
extrêmement classique sauf que ça nous a
échappé nous pharmaciens pour être
repris par des industriels qui allaient
chercher et répondent à des besoins à
des besoins de téléspectateurs à des
besoins de téléspectatrices air qu'on va
chercher des produits de plus en plus
élaborées chimiquement parce que on a
besoin de quelque chose de plus fixant
on a besoin de quelque chose de plus
élaboré et donc du coup on recherche de
plus en plus de molécules élaboré et qui
ont une efficacité mais une efficacité
est ce qu on a bien regardé la toxicité
c'est là où je vous rejoins monsieur on
peut être efficace sans être toxiques on
peut faire des choses simples et être
efficace mais il ya un marché dans
lequel s'engouffrent les industriels
dans lesquels les consommateurs
également où un moine responsable c'est
pour ça que je rends hommage encore une
fois à des gens qui font ce type
d'enquêté on est là pour travailler
ensemble tous ensemble
est ce que toutes les marques sont
concernées philippe le ray on pourrait
se dire les grandes marques justement
qu'on ne citera pas d'ailleurs je tiens
à préciser a précisé parler aux
téléspectatrices et téléspectateurs que
nous avions invité plusieurs
représentants des fédérations des
entreprises de beauté ou autres
syndicats ou autres grandes marques mais
voilà personne n'a souhaité s'exprimer
sur la question
moi je suis là bas vous vous êtes là ne
faisait pas représentants des corps en
partance n'avoir pas tout
toutes les marques sont concernées si ce
n'est que les marques les plus connues
font davantage de marketing et donc plus
facilement leurs produits voilà ils font
rêver donc à partir d'où ils font rêver
ils font pas peur peut-être que monsieur
à un fonds de commerce où vous voudrez
un peu plus faire peur que rêver voilà
après il ya des logiques qui
s'affrontent
bon en même temps même temps ça reste
aussi un marronnier parce qu'on le voit
ressortir chaque année avant donc un
moment dell j'aimerais bien qu'on arrête
finalement non par les enquêtes c'est
important mais qu'on arrête finalement
que ça se reproduise ce que j'ai envie
qu'il soit sorti de marché si c'était le
cas et moi je le revends dit de la même
façon que vous sauf que encore une fois
les industries n étant pas là je suis
pas là pour faire
ni représentant des uns des autres mais
personne n'a envie d'être toxiques
personne n'a envie mais on a envie de
répondre parfois un peu trop rapidement
répondre à des besoins supposé ou
artificiel a des besoins et des fois
vous faites peut-être un peu trop vite
faisons la chasse on semble justement
elle est demandée aux fins continent 5 1
au pied droit ce qui est pensé de cette
question est ce que les cosmétiques sont
dangereux pour la santé qu'est ce qu'ils
sont en france on regarde ce que ça
donne mais je fais un petit natation oui
à ce qui pourrait être enlevée par
exemple le silicone tout ça me gène muté
aux marques et je regarde regarde plus
je fais pas gaffe quoi j'ai vu et non je
fais pas attention
j'essaie d'acheter des choses naturelles
où il n'ya pas de votre produit chimique
achètent des choses il ya le moins de
composants possible en fait mais comme
ça je suis tranquille j'essaie de garder
la même gamme dans laquelle j'ai
confiance et un amour je savais ce qui
lui vaut la scadd dans et puis après je
fais plus attention
je regarde soient pas des parabènes
dedans phénoxyéthanol c'est tout cas et
je pense sur les produits bio et puis je
fais attention à ce que ce soient des
produits naturels avec le moine de de
produits chimiques possible marc et
gendres les réactions ce qu'on veut
entendre ben effectivement nous c'est
souvent ce qu'on entend dans nos
ateliers le public n'est pas toujours
informés il ya une grosse présence comme
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure du
marketing aussi qui fait qu'on va être
attaché à acheter ce qu'on voit la pub à
la publicité
parce que l'on pense que c'est bon on se
méfie pas forcément donc nous c'est
vraiment aussi comme je disais tout à
l'heure la démarche qu'on va avoir de
pouvoir décoder ce qu'il ya derrière
tout ça de comprendre aussi les
problématiques que ça peut engendrer sur
le plan sanitaire mais aussi sur le plan
environnemental et et pouvoir aussi bien
des côtés un petit peu là j'entends
beaucoup les gens qui parlent
oui j'achète il ya des produits naturels
alors attention aussi à ce qu'on appelle
le greenwashing
maintenant ce n'est pas forcément là où
c'est à dire que quand on voit sur un
produit à base d'huile d'olive à base
d'huile d'argan attention des fois ces
composants en fait sont un tout petit
pourcentage de ce qu'on va trouver dans
le produit donc c'est pas forcément des
produits naturels parce que ça va être
écrit écrit dessus à base de
tel ou tel produit donc d'où
l'importance vraiment de de décoder ces
emballages là est de savoir en fait si
repérer dans tout ça pour rebondir sur
ce que disait tout à l'heure
mustapha larbaoui on va regarder la
question la réponse par vaux qui a été
apportée par la fédération des
entreprises de la beauté
voilà la réponse donc qu'est ce qu'ils
disent
concrètement si c'est de l'intox donc l'
ufc que choisir lé enquête qui l'ont
qu'ils ont qu'ils ont fait que vont
réaliser cette livebox et ils ont
l'argument de dire tout simplement que
si ces produits étaient toxiques
il ne serait pas sur le marché c'est
simple c'est clair donc premièrement
fille d'effleurer un déni votre enquête
la ufc que choisir c'est de l'intox
ce n'est pas vrai et tout est surveillé
donc si ces produits étaient toxiques
mais sera pas sur le marché qu'est ce
que vous répondez aux anges je les dis
ces produits ils ont une autorisation
administrative ça on est contestée pas
seulement il existe dans ces produits
à dose peut-être infinitésimale mais
malgré tout réel c'est prouvé par les
par les enquêtes et par le moteur même
depuis longtemps c'est pas seulement
aujourd'hui qu'il ya certaines
substances qui peuvent être dangereuses
voilà même si c'est à dose
infinitésimale et comme je les dis il y
a quelques années c'est il ya des
substances comme le prenons le parabène
parti qui paraissait sans danger et qui
maintenant se sont révélées après étude
et approfondissement nocifs et ont été
remplacés donc créé dans une démarche de
qualité et de santé publique voilà donc
mais c'est toujours très long
souvenez quand même deux des nombreuses
études qui avaient été publiées sur le
parabène longtemps avant qu'on
l'interdise
alors qu'est ce qui fait que ça les
détend aussi mustapha la route à bord
pour réagir sur le reportage et le micro
trottoir
les gens répondent avec un bon sens
extraordinaire c'est à dire qu'en fait
quel est le mot le plus important pour
les gens ça s'appelle la confiance donc
si la confiance doit changer de camp au
temps qu'on fasse changer de camp la
confiance c'est à dire que si la
confiance sont dans l'est et dans les
marques les gens continuent à prendre
leurs marques si la confiance change de
camp et qu'elle va qu'elle revienne à
des magistraux comme le pharmacien elle
changera de camp et demain le changera
de camp pour aller vers des ateliers qui
font les choses en particulier donc en
fait les gens ont envie de cosméto ont
envie de rêve ont envie de faire des
choses pour leur corps et leur santé et
leur bien-être
mais ils ont besoin
de confiance et c'est de ça dont on
parle est ce que les industriels auront
la confiance ou pas c'est ça la vraie
question et moi ce que je reprocherais
finalement à ce type d' enquête parce
que autant j'aime
à vous lire et j'aime ce que vous soyez
sur le terrain et qu'on soyez qu'on soit
acteur finalement de ce qui peut
préserver la santé publique de tous
leurs proches qu'on peut faire c'est que
à partir nous on extrait quelque chose
de son contexte par exemple une molécule
est allergisantes
non je l' ai dit tout à l'heure un fruit
peut être allergisants pour vous et pas
prenons l'exemple du perturbateur
endocrinien à l'énergie a par exemple la
structure battant le mans ça reste des
mots qui peuvent rompre la confiance
alors qu'en fait ce mot est un peu fort
et il n'est pas très précis deuxième
chose perturbateur endocrinien je vous
donne par la définition je suis pas là
pour ça mais perturbateurs qui perd
turquie qui gêne au fonctionnement
endocrinien on va toucher le système
hormonal ou endocrinien c'est le système
c'est clair au club un perturbateur
endocrinien c'est un mot que vous
balancer comme ça vous foutez les
chemins tout le monde parce qu'à un
moment donné on touche au système
hormonal n'y a pas plus terrible les
hormones c'est l'insuline c'est le cas
gonds c'est toutes ces hormones
thyroïdiennes etc
c'est quand même fou qu'on nous les
redire mais qu'on nous en apporte la
preuve par contre si monsieur a prononcé
le mot de façon infinitésimale oui alors
si de façon empirique
la molécule est infinitésimal toxiques
et ce qu'elle l'est dans des conditions
autres que celles que vous décrivez est
ce qu'elle est encore toxiques est ce
que pour tous et encore et donc c'est
cette rigueur
manquerait qui nous gênerait mais encore
une fois pour le coup je ne ferme pas la
porte à dire tout ce que vous dites
c'est bidon la preuve c'est que des fois
ça revient en boomerang
on a fait un médicament qui est sortie
pendant des années quand dizaine
d'années pour l'épilepsie bas pour les
femmes enceintes compris ce produit
c'est quand même majeurs ce qui s'est
passé donc oui à des enquêtes comme
celle là pour alerter que les
industriels se disent tiens il ya des
enquêtes qu'est ce qu'on fait on regarde
si on peut se substituer par autre chose
tant mieux personne n'a envie d'être
toxiques
par contre un peu plus rigoureusement
quand même et pas forcément de façon
marronniers mais un peu flou voilà fait
des fleurs et vous répondra pas après
c'est sa mort né c'est peut-être parce
que justement il ya des choses
oui on va redémarrer jambes on entend
souvent dire on a entendu également dans
le micro trottoir faut des choses plus
naturel faut des choses bio lorsque il
suffit de voir bio ou naturels pour pour
rassurer les consommateurs et
consommatrices alors sur le côté naturel
j'en parlais déjà tout à l'heure sur le
bio attention c'est pas parce que c'est
écrit le mot bio sur un produit qu'il
est forcément bio un produit bio en fait
il va être reconnaissables par un label
qui certifie qui répond à un cahier des
charges très strict
juste comment nous allons nous en des
couleurs quelques-uns alors
effectivement donc il existe de nombreux
labels qui ne signifie pas tous la même
chose par contre il partage quand même
un certain nombre de points communs
déjà en premier lieu ils vont limiter le
nombre de conservateurs qui vont être
utilisés également ils vont bannir
certains produits dangereux par exemple
lui les huile de paraffine la silicone
des parfums ou des colorants de synthèse
beaucoup de produits issus de la
pétrochimie
par exemple ils vont aussi bannir
certains composants issus de gm ou
d'origine animale voilà ça tous ces
labels même s'ils sont très nombreux il
partage quand même un certain nombre de
points communs
maintenant par contre effectivement il
en existe plusieurs alors pour parler
des labels les plus courants donc on va
avoir les labels ecocert et cosmébio
donc c'est sûr qu'on va retrouver les
plus couramment à gauche mais attention
puisque en fait ecocert et cosmebio en
fait il ya deux sortes de la belle à
chaque fois on va avoir
ecocert cosmébio cosmétique écologique
est certain qu'ils vont être cosmétiques
biologiques et attention ça ne veut pas
dire la même chose
les cosmétiques écologiques
en fait seulement 50 % des ingrédients
végétaux qui vont qui vont être enfin
qui vont être dans ces produits sont
issus de l'agriculture biologique
c'est uniquement dans les cosmétiques
biologiques
oui il va y avoir alors non pas 100 %
d'ingrédients végétaux issus de
l'agriculture biologique
mais 95% alors c'est assez rare ben il
yad'autres lamelles label qui sont
beaucoup plus en plus voilà est par
exemple on allait la belle nature et
progrès et demeter alors qu'on va
trouver plus dans des magasins
spécialisés bio voir pour les produits
demeter ça va être beaucoup sur internet
qu'on va pouvoir les commander et au par
contre ils vont garantir 100 % de
d'ingrédients issus de l'agriculture
biologique donc une agriculture qui
n'utilise pas de pesticides et d'engrais
de synthèse et puis du coup on est aussi
sur des ingrédients végétaux et non pas
des ingrédients issus de là près de la
pétrochimie ou ou de d'autres substances
de synthèse
voilà un petit peu sur sur ces labels
pour cette réaction rapidement jusqu'au
jour où que choisir qui fait un
admirable dira que tous les labels bio
en apprenant que sa belle il faut
retirer suis là parce qu'on a prouvé que
ce qui est déjà le cas il ya un label
agricole bio qui a été montré du doigt
dernièrement parce que on a vu que dans
les usines finalement ils respectaient
pas forcément ce qui veut dire qu'au
bout d'un moment il ya des il ya des
gens qui font aussi du profit sur le
green
pour le coup
le green point il ya un moment donné il
ya des gens qui vont aller peut-être
dans une autre logique quand l'économie
s'en mêle ça que je veux dire c'est
qu'il faut faire attention souvent c'est
l'économie qui massacrent un peu tout ça
la régente d'abord oui alors vu juste
pour dire sur les sur les labels pour
ceux qui aimeraient en savoir plus il ya
l'ademe donc qui a publié un petit guide
très très semblables de l'agencé de
l'environnement et de maîtrise de
l'énergie et du coup à l'intérieur vous
avez bien pour vous y repérer mieux en
fait avec tous les labels
alors non seulement sur les produits
cosmétiques mais exact mais aussi sur
d'autres produits du quotidien et donc
leur signification qu'est ce qu'il veut
dire donc voilà ça permet à chacun de
pouvoir faire ses choix en connaissance
de cause bon bah pas de doctorat en
chimie mais probablement une thèse campo
kahn pourrait fumer alors ce que le
verset la criante c'est la confiance qui
prime dans tout et il ya des métiers
entre guillemets pour le coup le mien où
on a besoin d'eux d'engendrer de la
confiance pour être sûr que le
consommateur donc bravo à ce que vous
faites et en même temps ne jetons pas le
propre trop rapidement ou la panique 3
rapidement des faits réels et sérieux et
qu on avance tous ensemble on a tous
intérêt fait déplore un manque de
rigueur disais tout à l'heure on
s'affaire à huawei dans vos enquêtes
non je ne pense pas vous savez que je
sais que choisir ce qui est totalement
indépendante donc toutes les enquêtes
que nous faisons ou les des analyses que
nous faisons à son étonnement
faites par des laboratoires indépendants
donc de ce que non je pense qu'on peut
pas nous reprocher cela c'est que je
voulais dire en plus c'est que le souci
c'est d'informer à tous d'être cause le
consommateur ils disent il reste libre
de ses choix face la plus importante
pour nous et on veut pas l'obliger à
telle ou telle est la voie la messe que
ce que l'on souhaite c'est un besoin des
consommateurs actuellement on le voit
dans le domaine de l'alimentation
les gens veulent comprendre ce qu'il ya
un des produits qu'ils achètent c'est
tout après bon on va pas les font ce
qu'ils veulent on est tous eu ma fille
marion va profiter de la peut-être la
dernière minute mais il ne prend à peu
près qui nous reste safar veut il faut
taquiner un petit peu toujours tout à
l'heure en disant oui il faut vraiment
un doctorat ou vitesse pour peut-être
faire ces produits soient même mode coop
on sait reconnaître chimiste pense que
me donne l exemple qu on peut faire un
produit du quotidien pourrit dans
quelque chose de très simple
effectivement pour vraiment maîtriser ce
qu'on met dans ses produits cosmétiques
c'est de les faire soi même et donc par
exemple avec du bicarbonate de soude et
ben on va pouvoir faire en rajoutant un
petit peu d'eau du déodorant
ou alors pour fabriquer un liniment donc
un nettoyant les bébés ou bien pour se
démaquiller avec de l'huile d'olive et
de l'autre chaux voilà on va pouvoir
fabriquer sa très simplement l'autre
choc on pourra trouver ça sera très long
tout simplement parce qu'on la fin à une
époque et ça s'est industrialisé mais
c'est vrai que c'est complètement ça
j'ai donc des produits tout simple est
ce que vraiment très rapidement pour
terminer il ya peut-être une suspicion
généralisée là qui peut philippe le ray
salée dans la danse dans la société se
dire que l'exemple du vaccin par exemple
il ya beaucoup de personnes qui veulent
puissent vacciner maintenant parce que
m'adresse ont peur
oui vous n'avez pas peur que ça jette
aussi la suspicion sur un peu tout non
mais le but c'est pas de faire peur aux
gens non non non le but c'est encore une
fois d'informer d'informer voilà est
aussi vous savez bon tout dépend aussi
je dirais des individus des populations
si on prend par exemple les allergies
regardez par exemple parmi les enfants
qui sont allergiques à tel aliment ou
associés cela ce qu'on ne voyait pas
forcément eu auparavant un donc moi je
constate quand même enfin je parle un
peu sous contrôle des professionnels de
santé mais des allergies qui peuvent se
développer un ou bien pour les produits
cosmétiques aussi d'aider des produits
qui peuvent venir que non fabriqués en
france qui veut venir d'ailleurs qui
peuvent développer des allergies
ça vous l'avez vu comme moi dans la
presse pour preuve c'est que choisir
bien d'autres donc c'est pour ça qu'il
faut il faut être vigilant
la profession a raison tous vides nous
sommes la vigie nous sommes vigilants et
par définition contribuent tous ces
justes ne pas jeter le propre comme ça
sur un secteur d'activité qui voit là
c'est juste ça en fait c'est à mon avis
un peu plus nuancé mais mais il faut
continuer mais ce qui inquiète la région
d'où l'intérêt aussi d'accompagner ce
type d'étude par des ateliers de
sensibilisation qui permettent aussi du
coup de vulgariser les choses est de
permettre vraiment aux gens de
comprendre et de pouvoir encore une fois
faire des choix éclairés entre les deux
on va l'avoir trouvée tout ça pour y sur
le site de l'association donc e graine
août un peu ça dans un moteur de
recherche vous trouverez et puis vous
pouvez retrouver en détail sur dans le
dernier numéro de que choisir mois de
mars voilà tout l'anc est sûre ces
produits toxiques retrouver voilà dans
vos cosmétiques du quotidien merci à
tous les trois d'avoir participé à ce
débat c'est très intéressant
je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission en podcast sur
le site de tv fils www.tv fil 78 points
comme à bientôt et bonne soirée